so I fought obviously I'll keep it like
tonight and then tomorrow what I've got
caffeine in me yeah we'll go ahead we'll
go deeper more in-depth conversation
yeah man yeah man all right man so just
FYI guys I'm tired I'm tired yeah yeah
here for the content all right man oh
here for the content talk to me all
right man let me think where do I start
so what's a long ass list of topics that
I've been coming to me all over yeah
shall huge by the way mmm
I'm under said no free branding shout
out huge I love huge
so I fought actually this is like a good
thing yeah
I fought from the start of the episodes
from now on we could start with like the
feedback okay feedback loop rather than
either paying it off the end or or
whatever yeah yeah stand with you feel
about looking from the start so I don't
forget and leave these people out yeah
so okay so he talked to me first one
yeah I got was feedback oh yeah yeah
give him [ __ ] complexes and [ __ ] what
you mean company so perfect example yeah
I used to have when I was going out with
T mm-hm
we would like she would want to [ __ ]
every single day every single day yeah
which is blessed
yeah but obviously once you went
obviously when you you're seeing someone
for a long time eventually you see them
every day yeah and I don't wanna [ __ ]
every and everything yeah honeymoon
period is gang yeah yeah first six
months everyday bang gasps guys I'm not
in when you've been is like nine months
eight years like everyday for a year
relax pips that's 365 knots
so I'm not a seaman Brothers Bear seaman
millions so upon billions obviously I
remember the first time the first ever
time I said mmm no BAE's not tonight I'm
tired
she got complex phone even though we've
been [ __ ] nonce yeah yeah yeah yeah
but soon as I said baby not tonight yeah
she's just where is he you don't find me
attractive firm it's just like way of I
done all this stuff love to be fed this
is this is feedback but I don't have an
answer for them yeah yeah because I
can't help if I don't want not yeah of
course the same way you can't help it if
it what kicks kind of if they're not in
the mood to have sex we don't be like
our Bey's what's it about me yeah I
would never be like ah I'm about as
babes like isn't my beers my beer gave
much drawing what cuz they're next man
up like that so yeah the feedback don't
ask to not say to feedback but to bring
up the point I was asked to bring up was
about giving girls complexes so it
wasn't necessarily just about that
[ __ ] thing it was also about like
affection so it's hard to describe but
basically like guys can be like I can
only speak for myself
yeah sometimes I can be mad affectionate
mmm and sometimes I'm just not know in a
mood
yeah sometimes I want to say if we're
sitting on the sofa watching TV [ __ ]
sometimes I want to like cuddle and all
that yeah that gauge sometimes I want to
do that but sometimes I want to be left
alone
yeah like sometimes if there's two sofas
in the room I would I said I want to be
an alpha so far we're still spending
time together but I want to be on a sofa
where they take it as an issue it's an
issue it's an issue there's an argument
about to happen
I smell love and it gives them a complex
and as I don't I don't know what they
want me to do yeah but I'm the person
who sent me this asked to me to kind of
give like I don't even know some male
perspective yeah on why we do that or
how we can try and avoid [ __ ]
people's fears but mmm I don't have an
answer for I don't I don't feel like I
think whatever we do our partner with
judges regardless not in the sense of
that there they are
what's the word I'm looking for they are
purposely trying to judge us but it's
instinctively it just happens so like
you said for example if you're sitting
on one sided so far or see him one so
far and your girls come and see you you
can see a girl and she's on the other so
far she's gonna automatically think
wagwan as opposed to it's not because
she wants to think it it's just an
automated reaction mmm whereas a guy is
just chillin on a sofa cuz it's not it's
never that deep yeah my guys look very
black-and-white think yeah I was even
something because I'm doing it there's
always a great friend for women it's
always an like quite intricate intricate
they need to run every scenario through
there
yeah so yes yeah yeah I was gonna say
best advice stop just stable sit where I
want to sit don't ask me don't ask me
questioning is wrong mmm there's nothing
wrong that's exactly it yeah but I also
had a flip side to it's not necessarily
a flip side but in terms of like a male
perspective of things as well that
actually can benefit in this situation
in that I've been yeah this is it's
almost a critique of myself yeah but
it's founded upon these the way I'm
acting is founded upon by past
experience so go like I've been
experiences where girls like for example
let's just say you've got someone who
you guys have mutually agreed that it's
kind of pretty much just sex
yeah it doesn't necessarily have to be
spoken but you kind of hat you
understand what the situation is the
foundation is it's just yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's not [ __ ] up a good
thing yeah so yeah that and then
obviously you have one of your typical
Wednesday night should go over you have
sex yeah you use you stay around to
finish the movie in it yeah stay around
to finish the movie before you go so
it's not awkward you've just come for
that kind of thing and then she just
happens to be like laying on your chest
yeah you're not bothered about the time
here and then you're kind of like
stroking her hair and whatever rubbing
up on whatever and it's just cozy it's
nice yeah then you leave you're amicable
everything's bless and then you get a
text yeah I really like Tanya stroking
my hair now that makes me think that you
want to push the boundaries now and
that's my fault from thinking that yeah
you might just be thinking that was nice
when you did the a you might but I'm
thinking oh she's getting at something
she's in Jos a bit more she's hidden
she's [ __ ] him in that skirt she
wants more than this just sexting yeah
she's hitting that we have a connection
or whatever so then next time I go over
there I stay as far away as humanly
possible such a understands I'm not here
first I'm not here to be rub into your
body I just wear a Mac I just want a Mac
and dip whoa and it's it's harsh because
it's all my fault yeah she might have
she might have not thought that
whatsoever yeah yeah and I probably
could have just pour it up to her but I
didn't want to sound like a crazy person
yeah yeah saying I don't want you every
time every time she has to bring
something up or every time she says
something I don't want to be the
Dicker's like okay cool but just so you
know it's just sex yeah I don't want to
be that guy yeah so I end up being the
complete opposite extreme yeah and I'm
like don't talk about it but basically
show yeah make it extremely obvious that
that's how it is and that gives a girl
complex as well because she might not
have been thinking all this because I
text him that thing she might be
thinking like
yeah what have I done you just come over
here [ __ ] me now you won't even talk to
me yeah now you want to leave and that's
what gives them a complex
so there's definitely times like that
word times like that guy's fault my
fault my fault
yeah but there are other times when it's
just brother astray because I wanted
strike here today I don't want a strike
you're here
don't ask me any questions definitely
don't ask me questions if you ever
wanted to happen again because you bring
it up then you definitely know it's not
happening again boy but that's feedback
session I don't know if it was
beneficial or what but I think the
answer to it is probably the same as I
always say above just be here front if
you can yeah I'm so happy you said that
because I've got a point
good so rolling off B idea be upfront as
you can
so a chick invited me to a yard I'm not
gonna say when and she hit me with oh I
don't want to have casual sex anymore
and like she did she doesn't have casual
sex and monster she's trying to look for
something serious right at her and I was
like okay then another thinking all
right cool because I have we've had sex
in the past hmm
but then she hollowed me saying how come
a burlesque show has been a minute right
and I was I was down to meet up and
chill but she knew I wanted sex I knew I
wanted sex anyway hmm you know I mean so
one over chill chill chill chill chill
were smoking for ages because we hadn't
seen each other in a while go out for
time which was great and then obviously
got the vibe that she didn't want to
have sex okay cool I'm not even gonna
entertain the idea of having sex oMG oh
therefore holder 404 please the camera
is on some booty
autofocus [ __ ] man though well saying
was yeah she came I went over I read to
tell we'll chill it so I grabbed that
she didn't she didn't wanna have sex
okay cool hmm I didn't I didn't make it
obvious that I didn't care but I was
just chilling like I was just be normal
we was talking having fun watching TV
watch TV at the time and then we started
watching a show
was about sex couple was called it was
about it was a it was called and
lesbians guide to straight sex it was
weird but was jokes and lesbians cream
six it's the weirdest show I've ever
watched was on Channel four but we start
watching it and I started texting one of
my boys athletic and Toby hmm oh boy
like there's one buff lesbian on there
was a barf lesbian on there so we were
just having fun laughing laughter
laughing and then she was like oh why am
I not getting any attention I'm like I'm
here on I like this is what the girl is
saying I'm here aren't I I know she was
like you and you and your boy out having
all the fun because we were just
laughing lovely attacks on okay let's go
have some fun there so I grabbed her and
then she but she resisted okay cool
and then something else happened well I
was there for like five hours and then I
left
nothing nothing happened it's a long
time but we caught it be caught up we
did catch up for about two of those
hours Clancy try but it's high so that
was actually caught just chillin talk to
her because she's a human being as well
so after that she was like takes money
to get arrested said oh cool we didn't
speak for time but time and then she
hollered at me about two weeks later she
was drunk she was like where are you as
soon as I got that message I already
knew what I already knew what was where
are you yes so she went from let's show
I'm not trying to I'm not trying to have
casual sex right a tear tear deceiving
herself knowing what she wanted to try
and see if I would be like yeah cool one
let's not see that she knew for her to
think that he was gonna happen
deluded yeah and she realized that's not
gonna happen
so she messaged me straight off the bat
what'd you do it I was like finishing
work right at her this was like 11:30
like p.m. hmm I wasn't finished
I'm fit I'm about to finish working like
an hour so she's like I really want to
see you from that point I ready it was a
Monday so he knew she was tired like no
one says that on Monday yeah so I was
like yeah finished up we're at sock
winters and it she's like oh she lives
me my spot as well on the spot it was
like oh how come you she said no I said
back it off for clothes they she's like
oh why do it now is that what
why am i doing you know why you called
me over there's that why do i why did I
call you every because I said to her
because you wanted to get [ __ ] and
she's like oh really yeah then obviously
v5 I'm thinking and then as soon as soon
as I was I was tired that day I know
what I want to do is go okay for I'm
obviously I'm a good Samaritan you know
like I said before I'm just doing God's
work I'm a Jehovah's Witness I'm out
here going door-to-door you know helping
the community so I did God's work yeah
and then I started to get my clothes on
and I went to the bounce yeah are you
not sticking I was like nah babe it's
night I kind of play but I don't know
whether she took that right or wrong but
it just shows if you actually say it's
not that kind of party I was like yeah
it's not that kind of party but she was
twice anyway so whatever I was really in
the mood to judging because I was
thinking about two weeks prior oh and
she was like oh I just want this and I
just so true to two girls that's why I
said to you girls are horny the guys
mmm but because she didn't get what she
wanted the first time she knew that
there's no other way she's gonna get
what you want yeah true so yeah that was
the tangent of what you just said boy oh
yeah I'm glad you said that boy just say
what you really want I don't really want
I don't doubt the fact that she does one
more than casual but isn't it's never
gonna be with me because we've never
we've never had that foundation
regardless so I don't even know why she
said that to me I understand she wanted
to catch up and stuff which was fair
enough but we both know we both wanders
out set yeah yeah so why even play the
game obviously the game is the game but
I played that Katniss
it's the game is the game and profit is
also this is like another thing this one
is actually a bit dark and sad but like
also I think when a girl is feeling
lonely or vulnerable and stuff like that
yeah don't use sex as a way to keep yeah
to counteract that and because like
perfect example like I had [ __ ] you know
this was in uni mmm-hmm so you were the
head time so there was a time where I
got a picture random we were watching
mm-hmm this is what eleven twelve
o'clock at night mm-hmm
I get anyways you know what the picture
in the outfit yes all random go so
basically to put a flapping the flap
thing so yeah memory at the time which
throughout and I were chilling I get a
random text from a girl that I kind of
was just sleeping with yeah a few months
prior to that we hadn't really spoken at
all and I get a random text a picture of
her just wearing some next house next
outfit and I think I reply this must
have been like eight years ago but I
remember like it's yesterday I replied
fing saying you ain't wearing that yeah
yeah old picture there's a bear say you
ain't wearing that she said something
like can't find out I'm fine oh yeah
yeah so she literally lives 30 seconds
down the road and walking mm-hmm so
obviously spotted you went down there
she answered the door she was wearing it
and we [ __ ] and then I must have
stayed we must have caught up for like
half an hour 20 minutes and I was like
cool got my clothes on time to dip time
to go and she was like oh are you not
gonna stay and I was like nah I live
there why would I stay and she had a
single bed right I was like why would I
stay like I live over there yeah um and
I was a bit like that like it's not that
kind of party like you text me yeah
wearing some outfit she wants to get
fight and then and then like the more
she was talking she was like sad that
wasn't staying and then she actually
like kicked up a fuss
that I wasn't staying and then I had to
actually say to her big man was the only
reason you invited me round here so you
had someone to stay with you tonight
because all a housemate coincident all
our house metal out really all gone home
or something
so I said there was the only reason you
invited me around here so you had
someone to stay with tonight and she was
like well no not just that off don't
wait to see you but like yeah like it
would be nice if and I was just like
that's depressing that is babies and
it's really sad and don't use your body
as a way to escape your loneliness gee
that's dark it's really dark that's
really dark but
that's why sticks in my head like it was
yesterday I'm never thinking babes
I still didn't stay I still have way I
felt bad yeah Jesus is very was dark I
was like ladies man you could do better
than that gun and the thing is as well I
think because a guy can't do that yeah
he doesn't think about doing it yeah
like I could never I don't know I could
never use like sex as a way to spend
time with no way to come over let's
fight but I'm actually really low nice
it comes you're with me yeah yeah no
mate no man I've never really be
thinking lonely yeah and then think I
let me touch this let me take this girl
that I know just wants to [ __ ] yeah just
so I can have someone with me tonight
like it would never work and like I
don't know when I'm lonely the last
thing I want to do is spend time with
someone I don't necessarily want time
with yeah if you just want a bus or not
you can happen more than happy to you
bar actually spending your valued time
with someone that you don't really give
a [ __ ] about it's pointless you might as
well just go to bed you might as well
just go to bed I've known I'm not that
lonely I could be lonely and I'm not
that yeah yeah you might as well just go
to bed right it was dark man I wasn't
happy that night that was good though
bail a bit I was not happy that night
right on a lighter note I've got someone
here that giggly so let's think about
this one right let's keep it cheerful
[Music]
I've written the same one on here twice
that's but embarrassing me
oh this is a good one actually this is
actually a good one it's not even that
funny but it's actually a real issue
yeah this is actually based on like a
feedback one as well okay body count
yeah female body count obviously yeah in
this day and age what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] asks a girl how many guys she
slept with yeah what kind of pathetic
little [ __ ] asks a female
how many guys she slept with so this was
on the back of what we were talking
about last time this was feedback based
on what we were talking about last time
about the slack culture and how guys
don't guys don't who ghost life that
Saturday and then someone hit me back
and she said you're right guys don't
really go around calling girls legs and
like slut-shaming them and all that
stuff but they've got this thing about
body count and they want to know how
many guys you slept with and if it's
over like four then you're disgusting or
whatever stuff like that and I'm not
gonna lie if I find out a girl's body
count is high then I'm not gonna be
happy yeah but why would I ask that yeah
I would never ask
I would never bite like I said if you
find out it's different if you find out
then it's a bit like oh yeah especially
if I if I want to pursue something with
the person if I find out then it's it's
cool but it is this bit like but at the
same time yeah what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh ask that who asked that bro how
many guys have you said who cares it's
the same thing about when I said goes
looking for a guy's phone like what are
you looking for yeah yeah what are you
looking for here what do you want her to
say ah zero she's gonna lie but over
because if she says zero that's a lie
that's first of all to lie and second of
all you're a bit like oh yeah zero yeah
I mean yeah and if it's one you're like
who's this guy so you obviously still
loved him what you mean she's gonna [ __ ]
one guy it's like 25 26 are you very
fought one guy obviously you're gonna
leave me for him if it's to is a bit
like what have you been doing guys
they've had one long relationship but
you have had a rebound yeah we were the
better part like closer to fellow what
do you mean yeah and then three and up
is just a bit like why do you want a
night yeah why do I wanna know yeah and
it's this point as brief so like yeah
guys if you're asking ladies you're
their body counts throw the [ __ ] ups
just thought grow the [ __ ] are necessary
a pathetic it's very unnecessary
[ __ ] pathetic when I heard that was I
was violently angry man violently angry
because I want to
these people asking these girls this
panel what you doing because guys guys
don't really care
well guys shouldn't really care because
it's pointless like it's honestly point
it's a pointless conversation is
pointless topic and there's nothing to
be gained exactly even I feel like even
vice versa resort girls obviously like
to know but girls only want to know say
they can determine what they do that's
the only reason why do you want to know
so if I've let's say for example I've
slept with for example let's say F slept
with seven girls and she's asked me I
said help seven girls it's like okay I
can [ __ ] with that yes yeah you're not a
slag but you've got experience not too
much but they say forty she like uh she
either goes yeah no more okay I expected
that yeah yeah I'm offended
mine's always the yeah I expected what
do you mean you expected that I told
someone a number before yeah that was
upwards of wait carefully I know your
contract gave Lee people word it man
just say was there's no shame here wait
what my girls no shame me it was upwards
of thirty yeah and they said I for would
be higher hmm why why would you 30 fam
that's a lot of women I always have to
say like when people think about the
number yeah trying count to 30
it's it takes ages one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen point fifty six seven
eight it's long fans what I think we
can't do it in a breath as long as fast
as you can you can't do it a breath but
yeah she was I expected more and I was
like why why what do you mean more like
it's just not my mission
just bag yeah I wasn't broth but yeah
that was a weird one but yeah but I
don't know what guys it's a tough tough
tough topic mmm the tough topic because
like I said if a guy asks a girl then
you're a [ __ ] like why you ask him
regardless mm-hmm and if I go ask the
guy it's only so they the girl can
determine what they're gonna do next
mm-hmm that's exactly like that's the
only reason why they are it's true man
and it also another thing is as well as
like some people go through phases of
see we spoke about that goal before
which one bish mmm that she was a proud
so I can ooh they're proud brush enough
dick
I'm just married with a kid she's lived
her life there was nothing she lived her
life if my man asked the body count yeah
he's furious
keeps if he if he doesn't need to know
guess what he marries the girl they've
got a kid he's not he's happy
so if difference does it make he's happy
he's happy why can't everyone be the
body count is probably higher than mine
oh definitely definitely
it's massive how do you know it I don't
know what it is but you but I just know
that yeah a huge breath he's huge oh
good she told a guy our
she told our mutual friend that she'd
[ __ ] me whilst he was [ __ ] her I
know exactly who's okay
she now smokes I know exactly who you're
talking about
boys is one of two people it's one of
two people and I'll tell you after the
cameras off yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
how casual sex was sir she told our boy
that she [ __ ] his boy while I was
[ __ ] her man cuz he come up to me and
was like are you [ __ ] such-and-such in
it yeah you know and he was like she
told me and I was like while I was
inside her
see you guys were testing out some new
new digs today from the Normand yeah
this give us a Johnson all right cool
funny I had enough for one banging these
out spread them out man okay hmm do I
say this it could get a bit lengthy but
[ __ ] it it's been at least 20 rough okay
this might get a bit squirrely but hear
me out all right so you know when we
spoke about like getting your ass licked
yeah yeah yeah and all this stuff yeah
recently I've been thinking man I wish I
was into more [ __ ] God thank God what I
thought you were say Reece I'm thinking
you know let me try it
well that's not too far from what I'm
saying hi speaker obviously I'm not
gonna try because I just know I don't
want to do it but I speak I wish I was
into more radical [ __ ] okay I hate you
on that because I hear you on that
that's just okay let's just go to one
extreme yeah let's just hate say you
take a guy who's bisexual yeah or what's
the one with everyone pansexual as
always I don't know some I think it's
pansexual maybe but just I don't know
the difference to me I don't know
there's been buy-in Pam had I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
think I think with panic you're into
okay so yeah sorry guys sorry if I
offended you yeah but yeah it's a sound
pansexual I'm into everything yeah I
love eating [ __ ] I love sucking dick I
love um just think of all the things you
can love you yeah yeah yeah
is that yeah that you're just everything
is sick yeah and you just into also into
that agenda it's just a sexual it's just
the sex fam gasps this is all sex it's
all sex and obviously the point our the
reason they came to my head is that like
I've said it many times it's just I love
getting lost in sex yeah I love getting
lost in sex yeah the worst thing for me
when I'm in in it to the point where I
don't know if it's been five minutes or
five hours fun yeah and you're just
banging banging banging and everything
sick and everything less and everything
feels good and you're into all sorts
like my worst fear is when you said that
of a week that there's been more than
one girls try to lick your ass yeah that
luckily for me that's never happened
yeah no one's trying to Lamarck they're
not physically trying but he passed me
yeah but I don't want yeah yeah I don't
want when I'm in that mood picking up
anything throwing me out yeah okay yeah
otherwise growing out my there's no real
coming back to where we were scores what
the fake off them I'm not in there
anymore yeah you know in that space I
was in ecstasy a minute ago now you said
you wanna stick a finger up my ass and
I'm just like I don't even want to be
here yeah you've ruined it all yeah and
now I feel like I'm letting you down
because you want to do [ __ ] yeah and I'm
like yeah yeah no I'm the [ __ ] oh yeah
and now like you're the more like
sexually adventurous person yeah and I'm
the one that's holding back this
experience
okay I'm saying okay so we're flipping
it here that we are flipping okay I'm
trying to spread my like but like a spam
my-my-my-my spread I'm trying to expand
my with a spread my cheeks no I'm trying
to expand my mind in the air so yeah
like I like that perspective yeah
because I like I love getting lost in it
right that's my favorite thing getting
lost in [ __ ] yeah it's just the best
yeah and yeah I wouldn't want to be the
one that holds back a more flavorful
experience yeah because I don't want
anyone near my ass yeah and I
fortunately that's not gonna change yeah
yeah I'm not even saying I'm willing to
experiment on
I'm definitely just not why I'm into the
area and I just know I'm not if you know
me you know yeah yeah it's like I've
never had an oyster I don't need to try
and I never would never walk I just know
I don't like it here X there's certain
things you like we know you don't like
no one could tempt me otherwise yeah you
can name it something yeah I do think I
was thinking about it every day I was
thinking I do think it's a shame I do
you know what I empathize with that and
I actually do hear that because like you
said it makes us and now feel like we're
letting them down or like if a girl
wants to do it yeah genuinely wants to
do she's involved in sex she loves sex
more than you and I love sex but she
actually does if she wasn't amazing I'm
the one saying oh she loves more sex sex
more than we do and I love it
that's it's [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
I can't even argue with that
I can't argue with that bro I can't
argue with that
ladies that doesn't mean you can ask man
kind of like you asked I'm still gonna
say no mmm I hear where you're coming
for him I hear where you come from
that's a good point
apologize I think that's a notable
moment on the flip side of war what was
aim ladies do your due diligence before
100% because ass is always a gray area
yeah
so every guy's gonna have to ask don't
ask during do you do diligence yeah if
you are doing it they ruins the mood
yeah don't ruin the [ __ ] experience
just know that he doesn't either what
he's into a lot what he's in because
I've asked the chick before cuz I'm I'm
straight up with it oh I love a you know
and I've told you before I've told many
people and I've asked a chick before
does she like it and she's like Adam
Utley know like abdomen is that why
you've never tried you know if you never
try to just like no it's not me I'm not
into and I was like okay fair enough
but it doesn't that doesn't necessarily
mean I don't want to [ __ ] the guy or
like she's not as sexually motivated or
debentures me it's just not I think the
same way it's not the thing for me it's
exactly the same thing and it's good
they do obviously broach that topic of
course and there when you do [ __ ] it's
like we're all in yeah you can get lost
an egg and you don't even think about it
yeah that's funny about what you just
said about anal thing I never think that
someone said to me the other day was
when we're talking about
small dicks and like what would decide
Man Thing mmm like funny up someone said
to me someone flipped on me and said
okay what would you do if your boy
messaged you and said I really like this
girl she's this she's that
this is that but her vaginas [ __ ]
massive he's massive and you can't feel
[ __ ] oh my god and the funny thing is is
what I was flabbergasted yeah I was like
wow I didn't expect to not have an
answer by day and then she came back to
me and said oh I guess your boy would
have to just do like you just have to
suggest to your boy that he just does
anal and I was like to be fair if it was
food had it probably prefer it yeah so
he's gonna marry her what she can only
do anal gasps we're both living a happy
life ain't she in I don't see any way
but funny
that's calm you loving I like I like it
like a treat I know you thought I liked
it like a treat surprise tick yeah sexy
little surprising is like any new chick
I meet or anytime I've met the chick or
fact like not recently but like within
the last few years I've asked where
there was the one hoping for where there
sexy level is like what is their barrier
what's their boundary and if anals on
the cards I'm always gonna test the
waters here because if you say you like
it big man we're trying it yeah and I
would say nine times out of ten but I'd
say about six seven times out of ten
they're down for it and it works but the
other three or four I turn it's purely
because it they may like it but they
can't handle it mmm that's the same
everyone is because it's different for
every guy no every guy's dick is the
same so that's it well I guess all souls
was gonna be safe ass another thing you
might I might be wrong because I know
certain guys like seeing girls suffer I
don't like seeing those suffer it's a
big man and
no women please listen heed these words
please ladies please listen listen I'm
being deadly serious if you know you
can't hack it yeah
don't try yeah because it is unbearable
yeah to like try and you just give it
you get the tip in and she's screaming
and you retract and she's like no it's
okay just go slow I don't want to yeah
it's not worth it yeah but it's
literally not worth it
even in our out game anyway yarn Ewan
it's not worth it babes we can just [ __ ]
and this is exactly what I said about
the throwing you out of the funk yeah
[ __ ] like that yeah well your planet
experiments are for that yeah I'm not
even saying like it's a bad thing and I
yeah I love it when they're willing to
just expand and order stuff but in terms
of in the moment yeah babes get anal
beads for home get or do you do do your
home prep yeah and then we can imagine
it but don't experiment with my dick
because someone's getting hurt someone's
losing a hard-on yeah that's funny okay
my rebuttal to that is every guy is
different so for me I've said this to
many people in I've said it to you
before hmm I get I enjoy giving
pleasurable pain and you do and it's not
in a sense of like I am hurting someone
it's in a sense of I like I like giving
them the euphoria of not knowing where
to concentrate on because let's say for
example I'm [ __ ] a chick in
missionary yeah but with in the same
breath I'm choking her she doesn't know
whether to breathe or enjoy the dick and
that's a normal palatable pain yeah
every guy does that so we go and a look
and my girls are larger because they get
lost in that you for yeah yeah I mean I
love it I love it but when you said
about when you stick it in the ass or
you give it that like the one tip
obviously you play around with the foam
a bit get it loose yeah tight and then
you step the help stick the helmet and
she says oh but then she's like oh no no
go again
yeah to me that's a turn-on okay so yeah
maybe I was a maybe there was too much
of a blanket statement I'm game
if I can see that like they want they
still want it and they're not purely
just doing it for me
yeah so literally like yeah so like when
your face is like wincing yeah and
they're like um no no okay okay just go
slowly slowly and their bodies clench
now yeah the ass GE and they're just
waiting for it yeah like it like it like
jab in the arm yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
not here for that
I'm not do me any favor I'll like a lot
of girls what a lot of girls that I've
had sex with on flamboyan and off of
anal regardless like it's not in day to
day the yeah they're always gonna be to
try and press regardless yeah yeah there
are girls that are I don't know any and
but there are girls out there that have
a uniform and I'm true what there will
be anyway yeah I mean sort of them it
will never be like a you were just yeah
I mean I'm not very definite to be
easiest [ __ ] anal in the day is again
a [ __ ] massive dick in your ass I'm
not expecting it yeah easy
yeah what I'm saying may see the point
I'm trying to make with Vani I've only
just come to grips with now as we've
been speaking the point I'm trying to
make is don't do me any favors okay
so insects in general yeah don't do me
any only doing anal because you want to
make me happy
dardo okay because I'm like you said
with the pleasurable pain thing I like I
said I like to please people in it so
like if we're doing anal I want to do it
because ease on oh yeah if it's hurting
you yeah but I am still getting the vibe
that you want to do it because you know
you're gonna like it when it's in yeah
then I'm here for ya and we'll take as
long as it takes
I'm here for it as a turn-on but in the
same breath yeah if I feel like you're
only doing it because you think I want
anal yeah but you're you're clenched up
you don't want to do it you're kind of
biting down thinking oh yeah that's not
because it's not pleasuring him yes it's
not pleasure in there's no pleasure in
this it's just for me and I'm here for
it
if I want to have a wank firm I can have
a wank yeah like is this two of us here
and I'm gonna enjoy it more the more you
enjoy it yeah so yeah don't do me any
favors but then it
yeah obviously if you know that you're
gonna like it once we're rockin and
rollin yeah and I'm dead I'm here so
definitely here for about me
lady show me boy that yeah man
cool should we wrap this one up yeah
that was that was a easy breezy
earthquake and a breezy